L'importance de l'informatique quantique est à la fois sous-estimée
et largement surestimée en même temps.
Bien qu'elle ne remplace pas les ordinateurs classiques,
l'innovation quantique représente un nouveau paradigme informatique.
Les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent fonctionner en tandem avec l'infrastructure informatique actuelle
pour résoudre des problèmes complexes qui étaient auparavant
considérés comme peu pratiques ou impossibles.
Cela peut être un vrai changement de paradigme.
Par exemple, la difficulté de factoriser de grands nombres
en leurs facteurs premiers est la base de la
cryptographie moderne. Pour la taille des nombres utilisés dans la cryptographie publique
à clé privée moderne, ce calcul prendrait
à l'ordinateur classique le plus rapide plus de 300 000 milliards d'années.
Pour un ordinateur quantique à grande échelle fonctionnant
avec l'algorithme de Shor, ce calcul pourrait prendre quelques secondes.
Des problèmes complexes comme celui-ci existent dans tous les secteurs.
Les applications potentielles de l'informatique quantique
sont vastes.
Les ordinateurs quantiques sont déjà de plus en plus grands
et de plus en plus capables,
alors que nous cherchons à résoudre des problèmes de plus en plus complexes.
Depuis 2016, IBM a rendu les ordinateurs quantiques accessibles
au public via un site web avec une interface graphique qui
ressemble à une partition musicale,
et le kit de développement logiciel Qiskit,
qui permet aux utilisateurs de programmer des ordinateurs quantiques.
Des scientifiques au sein et en dehors du monde de l'entreprise
mènent des expériences
via des portails similaires. Ils explorent des approches en chimie
et en machine learning, essayant de comprendre
quels types de questions ils peuvent poser
et comment ils vont formuler ces questions
une fois que la technologie sera plus avancée. C'est maintenant le bon
moment pour les chefs d'entreprise de se préparer
au quantique. Les conditions sont réunies pour expérimenter
et développer cette technologie fondamentalement nouvelle.
Les organisations qui cherchent à être à la
pointe de ce changement transformationnel
sauront saisir l'avantage concurrentiel. Cette formation
te préparera à commencer ton parcours quantique !